If I did not know Brownlow well, I would not believe this story.
But I know him well.
Like all of us, he tells small lies sometimes but never big lies.
And he has no reason to lie about his newspaper.
He had the Evening Standard delivered to his apartment Monday to Saturday.
He was surprised to see that the name on the wrapper was not his own.
He sat back in his chair and began to read.
Within a couple of minutes, he realized that he was reading a newspaper about events in another world.
He looked at the date at the top of the newspaper.
November 10th, 2051.
But the date in our world was November 10th, 2001.
It explained that there was now no need to dig into the earth for coal.
It was cleaner and cheaper.
It solved the carbon dioxide problem that was causing global warming.
Apart from the importance of the front page news story,...
...the paper was full of unusual things.
There were many articles on scientific subjects,...
...and the pictures of fashions were especially interesting.
There were photographs of people in African and Indian cities,...
...and they all looked well and prosperous.
The only sad story was about the death of a gorilla.
It was the last gorilla on Earth.
The more he thought about the contents of the newspaper,...
...the more he thought it was real.